[MUSIC PLAYING]
RACHEL O'MEARA: Hi, everybody.
I'm Rachel O'Meara.
I'm based here in San Francisco.
I'm really excited to be hosting
our speaker today, Carter Cast.
A little bit about Carter, he's
here to talk about his book,
"The Right and Wrong Stuff."
And Carter just came
in from Chicago.
He is a professor at
Northwestern University
in the Kellogg
School of Management.
He is a active teacher in the
entrepreneurship and business
school courses there,
which is great.
He's also an established
business veteran and a venture
capitalist.
So Carter started his career
at PepsiCo and derailed.
So we're going to hear more
about that, I think, today.
I love that word, derailed.
And landed on his
feet, obviously.
He also was the chief
marketing officer, or founder,
of Blue Nile.
So if you actually
remember that company
from the days of
the heyday, I do,
then he was one of those
integral people from there,
and worked with
DoubleClick as they
were active with Blue Nile.
And also worked as the
CEO of Walmart.com.
So a lot of experience.
We're super excited
to hear about what
he's going to share
today about careers,
and derailing, and
getting back on track.
So please welcome Carter Cast.
[APPLAUSE]
CARTER CAST: Thank you.
Thank you.
So one of the
questions I get is,
why would you write
a book about failure?
So let me tell you.
What piqued my interest in
this topic was I had a--
I lost touch with an old boss.
And he was super fancy, the
right schools, and super smart.
And I lost touch with him.
And about 10 years after
the last time we'd met,
I called him up and I asked
him, how is your wife?
How are your kids?
And then I said,
how's your career?
What are you doing?
And there was this
disappointment in his voice
when he talked about his career.
And he hadn't reached the
expected level of achievement
that I thought he would and
that, probably, other people
thought, too.
So we hung up the phone.
And I literally wrote
on a sticky note,
what impedes the progress
of talented people?
And I stuck it on my
wall at Northwestern.
And then I decided it
was such a-- it's sort
of a provocative
question for me that I
asked the dean of
the business school
if I could take a quarter off
from teaching and just research
and see, are there certain
behavioral traits, or skill
gaps, certain
themes, that account
for people that are good, not
achieving their expected level
of development?
And so what I found
is, there are.
And then I flipped
the topic on its head.
And I looked at, what do high
performers that don't derail--
what do they got?
What's the right stuff?
And so one of the
major ways I did this--
I interviewed 100 people
who got fired or demoted.
I talked to a lot of coaches,
HR, VPs, executive recruiters,
CEOs.
But I also mined 360
research databases.
So I looked at thousands
and thousands of 360s,
and teased out the difference
between people in the top 10%.
People that were the top 10% in
managerial effectiveness, what
was their competency
profile set versus people
that were rated in the top
and the bottom quartile?
And I found that there's these
very specific competencies
they have.
What's kind of cool is,
it's not like they're
good at everything.
There's only a couple of things
that these people are good at,
but they're good at these
things consistently.
I I'll get into those.
OK?
So what I thought
we'd do here is
I will go on and talk
for about 30 minutes.
And I'm going to go over
these five reasons I found
that people run into trouble.
And then we'll take a
break and have questions.
And then for the last
10 or 15 minutes,
I'll talk about the right
stuff, what people that do well,
what these competencies are.
OK?
So we're going to look at
both sides of the question.
We're going to look at why
do talented people derail?
But also, what do high
performers do very specifically
that's different?
So first of all, this
is not a niche topic.
1/2 to 2/3 of us will
have a derailment event.
Either we'll get
demoted or fired.
I did.
So I'll talk about
that very honestly.
Let me talk about definitions.
When I talk about
derailment, I'm
talking about people
who didn't reach
the expected level
of achievement
by the HR department
or by their boss.
So they're not
people-- by the way,
this is not a
personal derailment.
I did not look in
this dataset at people
that derailed because they
loved living in Boulder,
and they wanted to
stay in Boulder,
so they didn't take a move.
Or they are triathletes,
and they wanted to work out,
and they only wanted to
work 20 hours a week,
or they had to take
care of their kids
and they worked
three days a week.
If they made personal
decisions that accounted for a,
quote unquote, "derailment,"
that was their decision.
I'm looking here at people
that wanted the brass ring
and were working their
tail off and didn't get it.
What happens?
OK?
The second caveat
to this is I found,
looking at all this
research for three years,
that organizations
are complicit.
They move people too quickly.
They ignore bad
behavior if the person
is hitting their numbers.
And they don't require superiors
to develop subordinates
like they used to.
You could say maybe part
of that's the gig economy,
but the problem is, as
a result, employees--
us, we, aren't getting
the feedback we
need in most organizations.
So I think it's wonderful
that you do events
like this so you can hear
from a wide variety of people.
So here are the five reasons I
found over, and over, and over,
in the research.
To make this more palatable
and a little less jarring--
instead of saying, oh, I suffer
from interpersonal issues,
you could say, oh,
I have a little bit
of Captain Fantastic in me.
So I created these archetypes to
make the topic less difficult.
So here's the first reason.
This is Captain Fantastic.
This is the fellow who
bruises you on his quest
for the holy grail
of the corner office.
He's ego-driven,
he's dismissive,
he's got poor listening skills.
I, Me, Mine is his mantra.
And we've all experienced him.
And he usually does well
because he's a self-promoter,
but then he hits a
wall at a certain point
because he gets in
a complex assignment
where he needs the
enlistment of other people,
and they don't want
to work with him.
And eventually,
you'll see that he
was moved to special
projects, and then
from there, six weeks later,
he's no longer in the building.
We know this guy.
So he has a relational
issues, overly ambitious,
driven by ego.
Now, let's say you're
not this person.
There's another aspect of
this interpersonal issues
I want you to-- maybe you
should pay attention to.
So this woman named Karen Horney
was a clinical psychiatrist
in the '40s and '50s.
And she did a lot
of work with people
that have everyday neuroses.
She found that we have three
tendencies under pressure.
We do three things
that self-sabotage.
She said we either
move away from people
when times are difficult.
We distance ourselves,
we're skeptics, we're cautious,
we move against people,
we're combative, or
we move towards people
by being ingratiating.
So that's Karen Horney.
So Robert and Joyce
Hogan took her work
and developed the Hogan
Development System,
which is a very
powerful tool that
looks at a whole
variety of things
from goals, to potential,
to derailment propensities.
And they took her
work and they found
these 11 specific
behavioral traits
that happen to all of us.
Under pressure, we
do one of 11 things.
We will-- you see that first
block, excitable, skeptic,
cautious?
That is the moving away
from the Karen Horney found.
Then, that next block
is the moving against,
by being mischievous, or
arrogant, or melodramatic.
And then the last
block is moving
towards by being ingratiating.
All of us do at least
one of these things
I've taken this test.
I had two.
My sister's taken it.
She had a couple.
We created this Zell Fellows--
Sam Zell-- we created
a program at Kellogg,
and we take high
potential entrepreneurs
and we put them in
this boot camp program
called Zell Scholars.
And we make all of the
Zell Scholars take this.
And all of them have
some of these tendencies
because we're human.
We're going to have some.
The question is, do
you understand your own
so that they don't hurt you?
So there is a recent Harvard
Business Review article,
two weeks ago.
Eurich, E-U-R-I-C-H. She
did this meta analysis
on self-awareness.
You ought to get it.
It's a great article.
And she said there's two
types of self-awareness.
Internal self-awareness--
do we understand ourselves?
Do we understand our
motives, and our weaknesses,
our strengths, our
vulnerabilities?
And there's external
self-awareness.
Do we understand how we
are viewed by other people?
And she said that 10 to 15%
of us have self-awareness.
10 to 15% of us, 85 to 90%
of us lack self-awareness.
So the Hogan is a
great way to understand
where you might have some of
these interpersonal areas that
are holding you back.
Here's a guy.
Right about this time,
this guy derailed.
This is me, right
about 29 or 30,
and I was called
into my boss's office
during my annual
performance review.
He told me I was insubordinate.
I was at Frito-Lay.
I was a senior
marketing manager.
He said, you're insubordinate.
You don't take my
direction well.
You're recalcitrant.
I had to look that up.
I wasn't quite sure
what that mean.
And I want you off my team.
And I said, Mike--
I'll call him Mike because
that was his name, Mike.
Mike, are you firing me?
And he said, not technically,
but good luck finding somebody
who wants you in their group.
And so I took two weeks off.
And I talked to my dad.
I said, dad, what do I do?
Can you believe this guy?
And he said, well,
your mother and I
are amazed you've made it
seven years in a corporation.
So he wasn't much help.
So I decided to go back to
Frito-Lay because I didn't want
to end on that kind of a note.
And I came back and found
that I had this reputation
for being difficult to manage.
And I finally
found this guy that
would take me in his group.
He's a Canadian.
He had just moved
from Canada, so he
didn't know my reputation.
And he took me in,
and he helped me.
But what happened was
I took this Hogan.
And I had these two traits that
if I would have known about
and would have been able
to manage more effectively,
I probably wouldn't have run
into this trouble with my boss.
This trait of leisurely is--
it's a weird word, leisurely.
It's basically when the
heavy hand of authority
pushes on you, you tend
to sort of blow it off.
I may or I may not
follow the direction
that my boss is suggesting.
And mischievous, in
my case, which is,
let's throw a grenade in this
meeting just to liven it up.
And so these traits I
had served me poorly
with a bureaucratic system
and a heavy-handed boss,
and I derailed.
And my point in sharing
this story with you
is, if I would have
understood this about myself,
I think I could
have reined this in.
Once I understood this
about myself, that trait--
those traits-- I
still have them.
I still have the tendency,
but they don't come out
to play as much because
I'm aware of them,
and I'm aware of certain
situations that stoke them.
So that is the first
one, Captain Fantastic.
Even if you aren't
that cat, that's
this arrogant and ego-driven,
you still probably
have one of those
11 Hogan traits
that you've got
to watch out for.
So there's a good book
called "Why CEOs Fail"
buy Dotlich and Cairo,
C-A-I-R-O, and in that,
they take the 11 Hogan
traits, and they list specific
questions you can ask yourself
to see if you have any of them.
And you will.
So it's the devil you know here.
Second reason people fail.
That first one, by the
way, is more in men,
and it's often as you get to
be higher and higher level,
you stop listening
to people because you
think you have the answers.
And you start
thinking that you know
it and you don't seek feedback
from the front line who always
have the answers,
because they're
closest to the customer.
The second one is
the solo flyer.
This happens, usually,
pretty early in careers.
What happens is you get a
strong individual contributor,
they get promoted,
and they still
try to do all the
work themselves.
So they micromanage.
They usually fail to
develop their team.
They hand out tasks, but they
don't develop the people.
Lominger Limited is a company
that does talent management.
Lominger.
They were just bought
by Korn Ferry recently.
Lominger looks at 67
managerial competencies.
It's a lot.
Most companies look at about 10.
They have 10.
I don't know how
many Google has.
But 67th of 67 in terms of
managerial effectiveness,
developing others.
It's the lowest rated
trait by managers.
So the chances are
pretty good that you
aren't going to
be developed well,
and so you have
to do it yourself.
The other thing that was
interesting in looking
at this-- because you
get the micromanaging.
You have to learn to let go.
Actually, Linda Hill,
this professor at Harvard
said, getting promoted
into management from being
an individual
contributor is literally
a transformation of identity.
We have to learn to go
from doing to enabling.
And it's hard.
When you're good at doing, it's
hard to let go of the doing.
So this third one that
was interesting to me,
Linda Hill also found.
She wrote this book called
"Becoming a Manager."
She followed 20 managers
around who just got promoted.
And she saw-- like
ethnographic research.
She kind of followed
them around,
took notes like Jane Goodall
did in "Gorillas in the Mist,"
watching.
And she said that one of the
things managers did poorly
was they didn't
realize that it's
one thing for me to manage you.
And it's one thing
for me-- another thing
for me to manage
this team, here.
But at least half
my time as a manager
should be enabling
this team to be
effective by building
bridges to other functions
where we have dependencies.
And so she calls that
managing context.
Are you managing the context
surrounding your team?
Are you building bridges?
So I asked people, if you
list your key initiatives
that you're working on,
and then you listed next
to them, the people that
you have dependencies on,
and then you list next to
them, what's your contact
strategy with those people?
Are you taking them to lunch?
Are you taking them to coffee?
When's the last time you
interacted with them?
You've got to be managing the
context because, obviously,
business is a team sport.
So we have all these
dependencies cross-functionally
that we rely on.
Solo flyer doesn't
understand that yet.
So the third reason for
derailment is Version 1.0.
And this one's
sort of terrifying.
This happens a lot mid-career.
You get complacent in your job.
You're good at your job.
And you kind of dial
down your curiosity.
And you don't stay up to
speed on cryptocurrency.
And you aren't quite sure how
AI might apply to your customer
service business.
You don't understand
what Audible's
doing to disrupt the
subscription model,
to disrupt the publishing model.
You just don't stay
current, and you become
this fossilized dinosaur guy.
That's Version 1.0.
So he suffers from
changing circumstances,
lack of adaptability, a lot of
times, to technological change.
But sometimes, it's
another kind of change.
He's not adaptable to
getting a new boss.
When I derailed, I was doing
really well with my old boss,
and he was a very
empowering boss.
When I got the new boss
who was more participative,
I had organ
rejection, and I lost.
He didn't lose.
I lost.
So that's the first one.
Then the other one is just
making sure you stay curious.
So I asked people that
might suffer from this,
how well are you honing
your discovery skills?
This is based on work from
Clayton Christensen of Harvard.
He looked at executives that
have either delivery skills--
he found they kind of neatly
break out into delivery skills
and discovery skills.
Delivery skills are like
analyzing, executing,
communicating, aligning.
And discovery skills
are these five.
So how well-- he also found
that people that are innovative
have a ratio of 6:1 on questions
asked to statements made.
So they ask a lot of
questions, a lot of "what if"
and "how might we" questions.
They also observe customers.
They go out in the field.
They go out in the
market and they
watch customers interact with
the product to understand,
what problems are they facing?
What kind of work-arounds
are they doing?
How can they
improve the product?
One time, I spent some time--
I teach this class that's all
about this stuff, called New
Venture Discovery at Kellogg.
You might know
the shoe Allbirds?
That came out of my class.
That was a student
in my class that
invented the shoe in our class.
We build prototypes.
We go out in the market.
We test these rough
prototypes, digital prototypes.
Then we build
physical prototypes,
kind of [INAUDIBLE] research.
Tim Brown developed
Allbirds doing a lot
of this observational research.
One time, I was
with this guy who
was the product manager
on an adult diaper brand.
We were doing some
research with him.
And I said, well, what's
it like to-- how long
have you been on the business?
He said, four years.
I said, what's it like
to wear the diapers?
And he said, well,
I'm not incontinent.
And I said, I know, but
if you put on the diapers
and then you pee in them, what's
it like when you walk around
with that on?
And he said, well,
I've never done that.
And I said, how
do you understand
what your customer is
going through if you
aren't wearing the product?
So discovery research is
being out in the shoes
of the customer and seeing
what they experience.
It's also experimenting.
I know Google is
very good at this,
and Amazon's very good at this.
Bezos once said,
I haven't failed.
I've just found 1,000
things that don't work.
This is A/B testing.
This is building
rough prototypes
and getting them out in
the hands of customers
and watching them interact
with them, experimenting.
Also, another aspect
of discovery skills
that Version 1.0 could
use is networking,
really establishing a
strong set of relationships
with people that have
diverse backgrounds that
can help you problem solve.
So really working on
your networking skills
is very important.
And then the big--
the Mac Daddy of them all
is associational thinking,
your ability to
synthesize diverse inputs.
The example people give
is George Mestral walking
his sheep dog in the Alps,
and then he comes home
and he picks the burrs out of
the dog, and he comes up with--
AUDIENCE: Velcro.
CARTER CAST: Velcro, yeah.
Associational thinking.
Einstein said creativity
is nothing more
than combinatorial play.
So Version 1.0 lacks this
discovery orientation,
and it's hurting
its effectiveness.
The fourth reason I found
that people derail is
this archetype-- is
the One Trick Pony.
This is someone who is very
competent at one thing,
but they haven't broadened.
So maybe it's a controller
who would love to be the CFO,
but she knows accounting.
She got us off QuickBooks
in our start-up,
she's great with audits,
but she doesn't understand.
She doesn't have any
exposure to forecasting,
or to capital asset
management, to long range
strategic planning.
And she's not going
to get the CFO
job that she'd like because
she hasn't broadened enough.
So this is a derailer that
hits us a lot of times
in mid-career, too.
We've gone narrowly up
a path, which is smart,
because we've become an
expert, but at some point,
we have to start
broadening our skill-set
and our experience
set if we want
to be able to keep rising
up through the organization.
This person suffers from
over-dependence on one skill.
So they're sort of
lopsided, and they haven't
broadened their skill-set.
They also may have a
key skill deficiency
in an area that's really
important to the business.
So for example, if you're
at Electronic Arts--
it's a local business.
If you're at EA, like I was,
what do you have to know?
No matter what department you're
in, you have to know what?
Something about what?
AUDIENCE: Games.
CARTER CAST: You have
to understand game play.
You have to understand
how a great game is made,
how you can make a game
addictive in 50 strokes,
is what they say at EA.
If you're at Frito-Lay,
you have to understand
sales and distribution,
because that company
is built around 25,000
route sales people putting
the product everywhere.
You've got to understand that.
She could have a key skill
deficiency in an area that's
important to the business.
And she hasn't had
enough experiences
that give her the ability
to see the big picture
and solve complex
problems by understanding
the role different functions
play in an organization.
So let's say I had this
One Trick Pony in my group,
and I'm at Walmart.
And this is the feedback she's
gotten, and I'm mentoring her.
I might do something like this.
Now, is my only wonky
slide, so forgive me.
It's my one business
wonky slide.
So let's look at this.
I might say, Gail--
let's say her name's Gail.
Gail, let's lay out the
critical path of Walmart.
What's the critical path?
The critical path are
the key activities
in any company that add
value to the customer.
OK?
What are the key
activities at Walmart?
We would write down
sourcing, merchandising, ops,
and store operations.
Then, we would say,
within those areas, what
are the critical
things we do that we
got to be good at to win?
And we would write down
supplier negotiation,
because you got to negotiate
for EDLP, every day low price.
Assortment planning,
good, better,
best for the assortment, right?
Making sure you're in
stock on the products.
Under logistics, inbound and
outbound warehouse management.
What's the inventory
software that
allows the product
to flow in and out
of these big warehouses?
And inside the store,
two critical areas
are planograms, merchandising
action [INAUDIBLE],,
and managing the 700 people that
are inside of a supercenter.
So those might be
six of the things
we write down that are critical
path activities at Walmart.
And I'd say, Gail, do you
understand these activities?
No.
Let's say, she's a controller
who wants to become the CFO.
I'd say, well, how
about we set up time.
A day.
A day with somebody who's
an expert in each one
of these places in the company.
Bet they'd love to have you tag
along and watch them for a day.
So in the next two months--
we're going to take six
days in the next two months
for you to get exposure
with a store manager
on how they manage labor,
understanding the planogram
philosophy around how we
merchandise inside of a store,
get inside of a warehouse
and understand inventory
controls and management.
I guarantee you, after
she has those experiences,
there's nobody that's going
to say she's non-strategic
because she's going to
understand the company
and the critical path of
activities that create value
to the customer.
So I would ask you guys
a rhetorical question.
What are the critical
path activities at Google?
And do you understand them?
Regardless of what
function you're in,
whether you're an engineer
or you're in sales, sales
and marketing, do you
understand the key activities
that Google does to create
differentiation in the market?
And if you don't, talk to
people who have a nice purview.
List those key
activities down and just
start familiarizing yourself
with those areas that
are outside of your
function so you broaden
your view on the business.
This is a very, very
solvable derailment area.
Captain Fantastic is
tougher because that's
a behavioral issue, right?
That person is going to
probably have to have a 2 by 4
upside the head before he
realizes that his ego run amok
is not going to serve him well.
This one, you can fix.
So the last one, and then
we'll take a little break
and we'll talk about
some of these--
this is the Whirling Dervish.
This person doesn't
deliver on promises.
Usually, it's a very creatively
minded person whose eyes
are bigger than their stomach.
They take on too much
they usually have
poor organizational skills.
They don't have a system.
They should probably
read David Allen's book,
"Getting Things Done."
They have trouble prioritizing,
what are the key activities
that I should really
focus on that move
the needle, the high
leverage activities?
And which are the
ones I can blow off?
Because we can never get
all of our stuff done.
So they need to prioritize
their A, Bs, and Cs,
and hit the A's hard,
probably ignore the C's.
They probably don't
understand process management.
If you ask them to
look at their projects
and do a Gantt chart
on them, they probably
wouldn't be able to
go cradle to grave,
what are the key activities
and how long they take.
So they might say
to the boss, yeah,
I can get that done by June.
No, no, no.
We're not going to get FDA
approval on the product
till May, then we got
to order packaging film,
we got to move the product
through the supply chain.
By the time it goes on shelf,
it's going to be December,
not June.
They don't understand
the critical path.
And often, they're
pleasers who can't say no.
And this is another one
of my derailment areas.
I overextend by saying
yes to too many things.
So a good trick there is--
first of all, I love the book,
"The Power of a Positive No."
That's by a guy named
William Ury, who
wrote, "Getting to Yes,"
the book on negotiations.
He's a Harvard professor.
He says, in "The Power
of a Positive No,"
remember when you
say no to something,
you're saying yes to something
else that's important to you.
So I might be saying yes to
my kids, dinner with my kids
and my wife.
I might be saying yes to a
workout for my stiff neck.
So that's one thing I always
remember as a reformed pleaser.
Another one is, Adam Grant
talked about this in his book,
"Give and Take."
He talks about the
five minute favor.
Maybe you say no,
but you spiff them.
You help somebody out so
it's not a cold, harsh no.
I'll give an example of this.
I was just asked
to go to Seattle
to give a presentation to high
potential Kellogg prospects.
And I'm in the middle
of this book tour,
and I'm teaching two classes,
and I'm a venture capitalist.
I don't have ti--
I didn't have time.
But I told the
director of admissions,
I can't fly out to
Seattle from Chicago.
But if you tell me the
three or four or five
people that you meet there
that are entrepreneurial,
I'll call them, and
I'll try to convince
them to come to Kellogg.
So instead of a
two day commitment,
I turned it into three
or four hour commitment.
So it's like a
five minute favor.
So these are the five.
Captain Fantastic,
ego-driven, doesn't listen.
What Saint Francis
of Assisi said,
seek to understand
before being understood.
Doesn't get that.
Interpersonal issues.
But remember, you might
not be a Captain Fantastic,
and you might still have one
of those derailment traits
that Hogan has in
those 11 descriptors.
Doesn't build and lead teams.
That's often
earlier in a career.
Super good individual
contributor
that gets a team and still
tries to do the work themselves.
Version 1.0, which is that
problem with adaptability,
and often, a problem
with learning.
I doubt that's going
to affect you guys,
because you're
probably very curious.
But staying curious and not
getting set in your ways
is definitely a derailer
for most people.
Being narrow, that
One Trick Pony,
going up in a vertical
way instead of
taking lateral moves
to get more experience
or raising your
hand to be on a task
force to gain your
exposure into other areas.
And then the Whirling
Dervish, which
has trouble
delivering on promises
because they overextend.
So maybe we stop there.
These are the five
things I found
in three years of research
that cause talented people
to derail.
RACHEL O'MEARA: Great.
So we're going to pause
here for questions.
We'll take some questions and
I'll let you speak in the mic.
Anyone have a
question top of mind?
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks
for being here.
CARTER CAST: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: Of the five common
reasons for derailment,
what's the distribution like?
Which ones are more common
than others in the research
that you see?
CARTER CAST: Very good.
Two of them affect more
people than the other three.
And they are Version 1.0.
I think that with the rate of
change that we live in, if you
don't--
if you shut your
eyes, things change.
It's staying curious,
learning agility.
Learning agility is,
are you open-minded?
Are you reflective?
After you do something, do
you reflect on how it went?
Do you seek feedback
constant-- on a regular basis?
Do you have those discovery
skills to go out in the market,
and watch your customer,
and talk to your suppliers,
look at the competition?
So that is probably
the single biggest,
along with interpersonal
issues, that are usually
driven by lack of
empathy and lack
of understanding the other
person's perspective.
Now, here's a caveat.
On my website--
I built this website and I put
my derailment assessment on it.
So if you go on
CarterCast.com, I
think it's backslash
resources, you'll
see this assessment you can
take to see which of these five
you might suffer from.
The number one
self-reported reason,
everyone is saying
they feel like a--
not everyone.
There's a lot of
people saying they
feel like a Whirling Dervish.
So my theory on
that is we're being
deluged with Tweets,
and texts, and emails,
and social media messages.
I think everyone just feels like
a Whirling Dervish right now,
period.
So that is the
highest self-reported,
but the research-- and
it was really rigorous.
It's those two I mentioned.
AUDIENCE: I have a--
RACHEL O'MEARA: Oh, hold on.
Let me get you the mic.
AUDIENCE: OK, OK.
Thanks.
I have a quick follow-up on
that which is, how much of them
are unique to a
particular archetype
versus a mix of a few?
Because I see bits of
myself in a few of them.
CARTER CAST: Yes.
That's a really good question.
A lot of times, different
stages of your career,
you'll flirt with
different ones of these.
So I was told I was a One Trick
Pony when I didn't understand
PepsiCo very well.
And they said you're
not strategic.
You're good at
getting things done,
but you don't really have
a good sense of strategy.
Well, I was 30, you know?
I was going to learn
that over time.
So the Captain
Fantastic is a tendency
I have with bosses
that micromanage
me that's very bad, that I
learned about mid-career.
I'm worried, now, about
Version 1.0 because of the rate
of change in technology.
And I worry about
Whirling Dervish
now because I'm overextended.
So I think it's natural
to feel like there's
bits and pieces of these.
In the book, I actually have--
this is more like a field guide.
I lay out the derailer
and then I spend
a lot of time on remedies.
So you'll find different pieces
of derailers that affect you,
and you'll find certain
remedies that might help you.
But I think it's
natural to feel like you
have pieces of
different ones of them,
especially if you
look over time.
You might have felt like earlier
on you, you're a solo flyer,
but then you became
a good manager.
And then another
one will bother you
at a later time in your career.
AUDIENCE: This might be
jumping ahead a little bit,
but I'm wondering, how many
of the successful people
that you talked to had derailed?
Is that a common thing
that people who end up
being successful also derailed?
CARTER CAST: I'm so
glad you asked that.
How many of these
successful people derailed?
So here's what's interesting.
We get all these speakers
coming to Kellogg,
and I'm sure you get
all these speakers,
and they tell these up
and to the right stories.
And it's just horseshit.
People run into career
trouble all the time.
And so my whole intent
of writing this book--
I mean, I'm a VC and a teacher.
This is just a labor of love.
I just feel like these
conversations aren't being
had enough inside of companies.
The boss should be sitting
down with a subordinate
and they should be
working together
on a development plan that
pinpoints some of these areas
and unlocks someone's
potential by addressing them.
It just isn't happening enough.
Talented people run into
this stuff all the time.
This is nothing to be ashamed
of, having one of these.
We're human.
We're going to have
some weaknesses
and some vulnerabilities.
The point is, and I'll point
out this in the next section,
people that do well are
on top of their own shit.
They see their own
derailment areas,
they see their own
vulnerabilities,
and they either
work around them,
or they find someone
who complements
them who can help them in
the area that they're weak.
So don't take away,
by any stretch
of the imagination, that
people that are really talented
don't go through this.
Here's what happened.
I talked to all the people--
I talked 100 people who
got fired or derailed.
80% of them recovered.
And those who recovered,
not surprisingly,
were the ones that accepted
the feedback, that incorporated
that this was on me to fix.
So sad.
Some of the people
that I talked to that
had gone on and derailed--
like, one guy I
talked to three times
in a row for the same thing.
He kept taking the feedback
and blaming it on--
the organization was like
this, my boss was like this.
And I just was--
my heart went out to him.
But I was a researcher, so
my job wasn't to play coach.
It was to continue asking
him questions to see
what he was doing about this.
And I don't know if he's going
to have an event, this one
particular fellow.
At some point, he
was going to realize,
this is on me to fix versus
projecting it on somebody else.
You want me to go into the
next section and then--
RACHEL O'MEARA: Yeah, let's
go into the next section.
CARTER CAST: I think you're
going to like this next section
because it's the happy stuff.
RACHEL O'MEARA: Good, yay.
CARTER CAST: OK.
So this will be a
shorter section.
So flipping it on its
head and saying, people
that are considered
to be superstars
in their organization,
what do they look like?
Are there any specific
behavioral traits
or competencies they have
that make them do so well?
So I found out that
there's a couple of things.
One is, they are self-aware.
B, they understand
their motive structure.
And then two, they have
two specific competencies
that matter a lot.
So self-aware.
What do I mean by that?
They are closer to those
who rate them in 360s.
If they say on a scale
of 1 to 5, they're a 4
in analytical
thinking, the chances
are the people rating
them say they're 4, too.
They don't say they're 4 and
everybody else says they're 2.
They have an accurate
self-conception.
People with inaccurate
self-conception--
I looked at hundreds
of thousands of 360s.
People with inaccurate
self-conceptions
derailed six times
more frequently
than those who were accurate
in their rating in 360s.
Wow.
That is based on Korn
Ferry 360 research.
Secondly, they put themselves
in the right context
because they understand
their motives.
So if I asked you, what's
going on in this picture?
What might you say?
Anybody?
What's going on in this picture?
AUDIENCE: Maybe research?
Looking at something?
CARTER CAST: So
let's say you say,
well, Beth and Joe are
working together in a lab
and they've worked
together five years.
They have a great
working relationship.
They really enjoy
working with each other.
You would show an
affiliation motive.
That's the lens you're
looking through.
Let's say you looked
at this picture
and you said, yep, Joe's
mansplaining, yet again.
There he goes.
That's a power motive.
You're interpreting it in
terms of a power dynamic.
Let's say you look
at it and said,
they're this close to
solving the Zik-- to finding
the formula for the Zika virus.
That's the achievement motive.
So this guy named David
McClelland from Harvard said,
motives are bare because
values are easier.
Values are what's
important to you.
So if I asked you,
what do you value?
You probably-- you'd
be able to answer it.
Maybe give you a minute or two,
but you could probably say,
I value intellectual learning.
I value my family.
But if I said, what drives you?
What are your motives?
It's like, ooh,
that's subconscious.
It's trickier.
So to try to get at
motives, McClelland
did this picture story exercise
which the Hay Group has created
into a assessment
tool where you have
to interpret a bunch of stories,
write down what you see,
and then a psychologist marks
it up and tells you what
your motive profile looks like.
So McClelland says, motives are
critical because they drive us.
So we want to be in a position
that maps to our motive
structure.
And he said, there's
an achievement drive
we have to beat a standard.
I bet a lot of you guys have
a high achievement drive.
There is an affiliation motive
to have close relationships
and love teamwork.
And then there's a power motive
to wield influence and enjoy
status.
So then I asked the people
from the Hay Group that
worked with McClelland,
do different positions
have different
motive structures?
And she said, oh, yeah.
I said, what does a--
what does a corporate
CEO look like?
What do you guys think?
What do you that'll look
like on achievement?
Pretty high?
What about affiliation?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CARTER CAST: Power?
CARTER CAST: There you go.
What do you think--
I said, does an entrepreneurial
CEO look the same
as a corporate CEO?
You're shaking your head.
What do you think an
entrepreneurial CEO looks
like on?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CARTER CAST: Good job.
Absolutely right.
I said, what does a
good PM look like?
And she says, oh,
they're the decathletes.
PMs, they got to be
good at a lot of stuff.
They've got a be achievement
to land the plane.
They've got to be affiliation
to get people that don't report
to them to work well with them.
They've got to be good
on power because people
that don't report
to them, they got
to cajole them into getting
their jobs done, too.
They get paid a lot
because they're really
talented across all
three of these motives.
So I took the test.
Here was little Carter.
Super high in achievement drive.
Every picture I
interpreted was, they're
accomplishing something.
High in affiliation.
So I used "we" a lot.
We're doing this.
They are doing this.
And very, very low in power.
And so the woman,
the psychologist that
did my assessment,
said, what was
it like to be a CEO of a
multibillion dollar company
when you have such low power
drive compared to typical CEOs?
And you know what I said?
I didn't like the job.
I was in the wrong job.
When I was president, I was
back in Brisbane, California,
just down the road, here,
and working with the software
developers, and
working with the mar--
we're developing the
product and I loved it.
Then, I got promoted
to be the CEO,
and my job was to
work with analysts.
It was to deal with class
action lawsuits, legal issues.
All of a sudden, to
influence groups of people,
and I would have rather
been back working
on the product with a team.
So people in there
with the right stuff,
they put themselves in
the right work context.
They understand
their motivators.
And they're self-aware about
their strengths and weaknesses
and vulnerabilities,
so they put themselves
in jobs that give them energy.
And I can tell you
firsthand, that what I do now
as a venture capitalist
and a teacher
fits my motives structure
a lot better than C--
I don't get paid as much,
but it fits my motive--
I'm much happier.
So in the book, I
list these motives.
And I added two more
after talking to Dan Pink
and doing some more research.
Dan Pink wrote "Drive."
He says, Carter, you
got to add autonomy,
wanting to have
discretion over your work.
And you got to add
purpose, right?
Mission, driven, some people
are just very mission driven.
They want to work in
Cleantech, or they
want to work in education,
or health care reform.
So in the book, I take each
of these five motives--
and here, I just gave
you a sample of two,
but I ask eight questions
around each of these areas.
So for example, I'm
very driven by autonomy.
I do my best work when I have
freedom to run with my ideas.
I would rather struggle with
the answer than be told it.
So if you think that you might
question your motive structure,
in the book I have
eight questions
in each of these five
areas to really think
about that might help you
understand what drives you,
and is the position you're
in appealing to your motive
profile?
Because people with
the right stuff,
they put themselves
in the right positions
to succeed because
they naturally
work where they have energy.
AUDIENCE: Because I'm similar to
you as achievement is important
to me, power isn't.
But normally, when you
see a lot of these things,
they're just together as getting
to the top and being the best.
CARTER CAST: Yeah.
So achievement is, you want
to be scored on your work.
You want to be able to see the
results in your contribution.
Power is, you want to wield
influence over others,
and you enjoy the status.
So if I look at power up here,
I enjoy running clubs and--
I've never run a damn thing
in my life until I was a CEO.
But growing up, I was
never a leader like that.
It just wasn't something I did.
I was always swimming,
or in clubs that
were about self-betterment.
So they're very different.
They feel like one
might lead to the other.
Achievement might lead
to power, but the motive
itself is pure in that,
if you like achievement,
it's really about you
wanting to measure yourself
against the standard
and beat it.
So here's a last big thought.
I told you there are two
competencies that matter a lot.
OK, look at this.
So most organizations
have, what?
10 competencies.
Some have 8, some have
12, but the average is 10.
If you're only good--
if you're only rated
in the top quartile
in managerial effectiveness, in
build strong relationships, one
competency, the
chances are 12% you're
in the 90th percentile
of your company
in managerial effectiveness.
If you only have
one and it's drive
for results, if that's the only
competency you have out of 10,
and that's the one that
you're in the top quartile,
the chances are 14%.
You're in the 90th
percentile in your company
in managerial effectiveness.
But look what happens when
you have the two of them.
Builds strong relationships
and drives for results,
the chances are 72--
you don't have to have any
of the other 8, on average.
If you have those
two, the chances
are 72% that you're
in the top, you're
in the 90th percentile in
managerial effectiveness.
Makes sense, doesn't it?
You build strong relationships.
You build bridges with
other departments.
You seek to understand
before being understood.
You're empathetic.
You understand the other
departments' objectives,
and then they end up--
reciprocity.
They end up wanting to help you.
You build bridges, and
you drive for completion.
If you add to those
two, being self-aware,
so you put yourselves
in the right positions
given your gifts,
that's the right stuff.
That's the formula, right there.
So capable people
derail because they
don't have a good understanding
of their blind spots and skill
gaps.
And people with the right
stuff seek constant feedback
so they can improve.
And they're more self-aware,
so they can manage around
their vulnerabilities
and put themselves
in the right positions
given their strengths.
That's it.
With that, we can talk.
RACHEL O'MEARA: Yeah, so
we'll open it up to questions.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
CARTER CAST: Thank you.
RACHEL O'MEARA: All
right, questions.
CARTER CAST: Does that
surprise you guys,
to see that you have
all these competencies
and there's only a couple
that really, really matter?
It made me feel better.
Like, wow.
Really focus on these two areas.
RACHEL O'MEARA: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What do
you think, having
gone through this process and
written this book, looking back
at your previous
career you really
wish you would have known
in your 30s, in your 20s?
CARTER CAST: Yeah,
that's a good question.
So can I write on a white board?
RACHEL O'MEARA: Yeah, go for it.
We can bring it over.
CARTER CAST: There we go.
So this is the back
of the brontosaurus.
Let's say you're at a
company that's mature.
This is size of company,
and this is time.
This is the growth stage.
This is the scale stage.
This is the startup phase.
And this is the incubate stage.
This is probably where
you're getting funding.
You're starting the
idea, so you need
to have a certain
skill-set here, right?
You've got to have that
associational thinking,
you've got to be out in the
market and finding the need,
finding the job to be
done, creating the idea.
You have to be optimistic, you
have to be resilient as hell
because everyone says
no to you all the time.
You have to be a
good salesperson
to get people to work with
you and to convince people
to loan you money.
Then, you start up,
and all of a sudden,
you start needing to
have some good selling
skills, some good
marketing skills,
you got to raise capital.
Scale, you've got to get
processes and procedures
in place to be able to scale.
And you have to understand
organizational design.
You have to figure out
product iteration and product
extension.
Here, you have to understand
partnerships, business
development, you're going
into international markets.
What's the next
version of the product?
How do you keep it alive?
And then boom.
You're talking about complex--
being effective in a
complex organization,
cost management, how to
reinvigorate a brand.
I'm on the board of Kellogg
company, the cereal company.
How do you reinvigorate
that brand?
So these stages-- here's what
I wish I would have known.
I played here, 11 years at
PepsiCo, $50 billion company.
And I was always butting up
against my own derailment
tendencies.
Then I went here, to Electronic
Arts, when it was 600 million.
And now, it's what?
It's mark caps,
like, 30 billion.
And I felt much more natural
because it was chaotic,
and it appealed more to my
enjoyment of that speed.
Then I went down
here with two guys
and started Blue Nile, before
it got Series A funding.
And I realized that I loved
this state, right in here.
So one thing I wish
I would have known
is I should have slid down
that brontosaurus sooner,
and gotten into these
environments that
are more for me, better fit
my own personality profile.
This was fun.
This was really fun.
This was torturous for
me with my personality,
just with my natural
motive structure.
So understanding not only the
industry you want to play in,
and not only the function
you want to play in,
but where in the stage of the
company do you want to play?
RACHEL O'MEARA: Yeah.
Well, I had a question about--
so knowing that you were the
CEO of Walmart and a mature part
and thinking it wasn't for
you, when did you know that,
and what was your
strategy there?
CARTER CAST: There specifically,
something happened.
So I went to Walmart--
We did Blue Nile, then I went
to Walmart when it was here.
There were 30 of us starting it.
And it was crazy, and we
made a bunch of mistakes,
and it was chaotic,
and it was fun.
And then we got up into
here, and I was the CEO.
And then they wanted to move
me to get trained under someone
to be the CEO for Sam's Club.
That was my next move.
And I had a good review.
And I drove home.
I had a condo in Bentonville
and lived out here.
And I drove back,
and I realized,
I don't have any
energy right now.
What's going on?
Why am I not thrilled
with this big opportunity?
And I realized that
I didn't think of it
in the terms of motive structure
like I just talked about today.
Something was not right for me.
And it was because I
would have been playing up
in here again at Sam's Club.
And I liked playing in here.
So what I did naturally
was I left the company
and I went back to another
early stage startup up again.
I'm not saying
anything evaluative
about being in a mature company.
It wasn't right for me
given my personality.
That's what I'm saying,
not that this is-- there's
many wonderful jobs up here.
It just wasn't for me.
RACHEL O'MEARA: I think we have
time for one more question.
We got one more?
AUDIENCE: You talk a lot about
personal skills and things
like that, but then
you talked about
how your reactions were
with different managers,
so how important
do you think having
an effective and strong
manager is in career growth
and being able to
correct yourself as well?
CARTER CAST: Yeah, I was--
I can tell you, the guy's
name was Stephen Quinn,
the Canadian.
I brought him to Walmart.
Once I got to Walmart, he became
the chief marketing officer
of Walmart.
Because he was such a wonderful
manager, he saved my career.
It's so important, I
can hardly express it.
Let's say you have
a bad one, though.
Let's say you're under
somebody who's ineffective,
or they're a Captain Fantastic
and they don't give--
it's really important--
people say well,
it's important to have a mentor.
It's important to have--
I don't think of
it as one mentor.
I think of it as, you want
to plug into smart people
different places of
your organization
to learn from them, but also to
have safe haven if you need it.
I was out in a job out here.
I had to drive to
Pleasanton every day,
before the Bart
came through, and I
was under a boss
that was ineffective.
And I ended up finding
safe haven-- for somebody
who had been a informal mentor,
I said, this isn't working out.
And he goes, come join my group.
So I think what
you want to do is
you want to have multiple
people you can count on,
not one Obi-Wan Kenobi mentor.
But a bunch of people
in different departments
that you can say,
hey, can I buy a cup
of coffee and can you help me
reason through this problem
I'm facing?
And the chances are
pretty good you'll
find safe haven with somebody
when there's a re-org
or something, and
you'll be able to take
advantage of that relationship.
And it's actually
fulfilling for them, too,
if a smart person like
you would want me.
You'd seek me out for my advice.
So I wouldn't hesitate.
I think when people put
this moniker of mentor,
it sounds so heavy, like
there's this obligation.
I don't think of it that way.
I think of having five or six
different counselors that you
can just go to now and again.
RACHEL O'MEARA: Great.
So I think we're out of time.
CARTER CAST: OK.
RACHEL O'MEARA: Thank
you so much, Carter Cast.
CARTER CAST: Thank you guys.
RACHEL O'MEARA: Thank you.
CARTER CAST: This was fun.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]